今日はさっちゃんですはいという意味ですねザッツになってきましたねー
結構いろんな場所でもう30度越えてぐらい熱いんですけども
夏といえばサイダー伸びますよねサイダー好きでしょ
歳だっていうのがあるんですけどもなんか最近ファインだってものすごいいろんな種類
がありまして
で何度ですよ東急ハンズにものすごい量のサイダーが売ってました
ああああああ
ん
選べますはいこれで全部です
大開脚で合計44のライダーを準備しました
多分なんですけど僕の経験上ほぼ全国のありとあらゆるサイダーをかき集めたんだと
思いますこの種類はマジでヤバいと本当にいろんな味があるんでちょっとさーっと見て
いきましょうちょっと多くてめんどくさいもう最初から谷川彼方シークは去った
ですねキムチ love でもうめちゃくちゃルヴァーナラムネわさびラムネマンゴー
サイダー美味しいそうマスクメロンサイト嘘ホワイトソーダとブラックもコーラ山ね
もうなんかそれっぽいので日出てきてあってたこ焼きルラ船から胸コンポタージュパン
インサイダー白ももサイダーでもねーど
塩レモンサイダーマスカットだ胸チラを守ら船だ俺の地元提案はブラックサイダー
シャインマスカットサイダーへカレーパン3位だ金沢カレーコーラー
なんで作っ
ま猫ちゃんださくらコーナー新種杏子サイダー俺は待ってクリームシチューラグで
多いなんで青い子ゾウメロンパンサイダー湘南ゴールドサイダー山梨ぶどうサイダー
横須賀海軍ラムネ瀬戸地でもラムネ完熟桃サイダー甘酒コーラ
ドリアンサイダーねっ
まっつらむねなんでっ
水カラムに美味しそう元祖ビー玉ラムネあまおうサイダー三ヶ日みかんサイダー美味し
そう
無駄にコーラーなんでっ
待望追加サイダー待ってヘイボードって何なんかハイボールっぽい味のお酒っぽい
スネ夫酒じゃないらしいので一応サイダーのくくりだと思いますスイカサイダー
富士山サイダー夕張メロンサイダー信州りんごサイダー瀬戸内なしラムネ
何作ってもいう意味のわからないこのサイダー等応
パート4等分お前はこれがどういうことを意味してるかわかるからそうだ
そうだなだけにこの日本中にあるありとあらゆるサイダーを一つにまとめることによっ
て一番おいしいサイダーがー
できるのさあほんと味がどうなるかも書かなきゃ音からやばいの多くないまぁそんな中
ちょっと頑張って仕事のサイダーを混ぜてどんな味になるのかちょっと飲んでみようと
思いますやっぱみんなないなら色んな子だしてと思うんですけどもおいしいものを
作ろうと思ってパン作ってるわけですよねそれを全て混ぜるとても美味しいこと間違い
ないんで全部マジで飲んでみようと思いますそれは5 year
空いている場所のひと混ぜていきましょう
[音楽]
中になって相談さんだから早くいる姉とダメなんだ
やばい
強い
あぶねー
なんて気持ち歳学生ばがルームねー
[音楽]
ファー
dee
ホントうわあああっあってドリアンくさー
ではやばいやばい
a これ
これ入れてよかったなぁ
[音楽]
wh
イェイ
指ああ
うわぁは良い by いいっこの大変だよった
ハイガーを着とこれ
絶対出ちゃう
はい武芸いるからこれええ
ています
re ああああ
ゲームはどうなるんだこれ
姉さんだと思ったけど
梅はキュッ
うなぎコーラを飲んでしかないんだよなぁ
うまいなんで全部美味しいかもしれんなぁ
あレイパーサイダー飲んでみたい住んでいただきます
[音楽]
難波南全部美味しいの
ああああああああ
[音楽]
最後はもちろん元祖で締めようと思います止まって44本全部けど本当に疲れたささぁ
ああああああああ
はいというわけでこれ1丁全部混ざりました色を見てもらうと分かると思うんですけど
納豆オレンジみたいな感じの色になりますねぇ
[音楽]
なんだ目パック4だとかあったから歌詞じゃないですけど赤っぽい色になりましたよね
これはちょっと混ぜてみないとわからなかったですねあー早速炭酸が通知に飲んじまい
ましょうか
ただし今の日本にあるサイド忘れてましたらなぁー宮津になるのでしょうか
だったっつーかも
me
hey 本当にわからへ投げちゃんだよこれ
どんぐり
me
me あった
いろんな味が交差してなんかわかんないですけどなんかどんぐりの味がしましたどんな
に食ったことねーなってなんか曲がりな宅地というかフルーティードングリーンですね
[音楽]
みんなああ